of the kentucky derby back with full
in-person attendance this year they're
expecting 45 000 people and we all know
it means horses it means hats it means
mint juleps but food is also a big draw
joining us to share some of those dishes
that you can make at home ahead of the
derby is derby head chef kenneth
hardiman chef thank you so much for
being here today
heather thank you for having me on i'm
excited well so i hear that it takes
thousand pounds of vidalia onions to
make this happen
oh yes we we're probably pushing a
little bit over but yeah definitely for
the dishes and what we're preparing for
this year's derby well let's talk about
what you're preparing this year so let's
get right into it i want to see the
creation what have you got for us
all right so one of the corrections that
we have for your at home derby party we
have the vidalia onion in bourbon tartar
tan it's a spin off of a classical
french dish that i love we have our
butter melted in our cast iron skillet
we're going to add some sugar this is
going to create our caramel sauce but
then we're going to take our slices of
vidalia onion and layer them in the pan
if you don't have the holes of philip
you're going to take the pieces of the
badaya and just plop them in there to
just make sure it covers the whole pan
make sure your caramel is spread evenly
uh we'll season it with some salt and
some pepper and then uh one of the
things i like to do is take some fresh
thyme leaves and sprinkle on top of the
onions it's a great accent to vidalians
into sweetness and then we're going to
deglaze it with some water to uh help uh
fortify that caramel sauce
then the secret weapon bourbon bourbon
bourbon bourbon maybe take a sip while
you're making this as well
then we're going to add our puff pastry
sheets on top of this uh seal the edges
of the puff pastry in it and then it's a
bake ready for the oven uh we'll pop it
in the oven and bake it until it is done
once that is done we'll pull it out let
it cool down to room temperature and
here's the tricky part here probably the
fun part too as well you get to flip it
out
um and test your skills and see if
you're able to do this and pop it out
and then voila you have the vidalia
onion and bourbon tart to tan i like to
finish off with a little salt that's
going to bring out and the sweetness of
the vidalia onions if they're bruleed
and nice and caramelized finish it with
some local goat cheese and then also
some more fresh thyme to get those
flavor pockets in there
then i like to drizzle it with a little
bit of local honey at the very end um
your pie is ready to go i mean look how
beautiful that looks oh my goodness take
a wedge of that and then um plate it up
and then uh finish it off with some
fresh cracked cracked pepper and then
bon appetit you're ready to go meat and
savory real quick chef where do folks
get these vidalia onions because i don't
see them all the time in the stores
well there's a very short season for
them it's only the windows from april
through august so i would highly
recommend if you're able to to get these
videos they're sweet little gems you can
eat them raw you can eat uh get their
natural sugars caramelized down and i
actually have some other recipes that
you're able to find if you want to cook
other things with vidalia onions at
www.kentuckyderby.combackslashparty and
if you want more information on vidalia
onions as well go to
vidaliaon.org please oh i absolutely
love it if we can't make it to the derby
this year to see you which of course we
wish we could we'll make it at home and
drink a little bourbon and toast to all
the ponies chef thank you so much for
the great ideas that looks absolutely
delicious
good luck to you thank you so much for
having me yeah good luck on derby day
we'll see you soon